[Musique]
n'aura pas les mêmes problèmes qui ont mis fin à
notre monde sur terre,
allez maintenant
recommencer en initiant le premier trimestre
ces enfants sont l'avenir de l'
humanité
[Musique]
vous allez élever ces enfants
pour qu'ils soient athées c'était la croyance en l'
irréel qui a détruit  la terre
nos ennemis ont construit une arche qui se
dirige maintenant vers ici
la seule planète connue où les humains peuvent
survivre et si jamais l'arche de mithraïque arrivait
ici,
vous n'écouterez pas leurs paroles, ils
croient que permettre aux androïdes d'élever
des enfants humains
est un péché que
nous devons sauver  nos enfants volés
ne leur dites pas ce que je suis
je veux vous parler sans l'
androïde pendant une seconde
elle n'est pas là elle
elle est lui captif il a besoin d'être avec d'
autres humains
je pensais que nous étions synchronisés père nous avons de
plus en plus pris  aux
impulsions
combien de personnes avez-vous tuées sur terre
vous êtes tous mes enfants
je ne suis là que pour vous protéger
elle est l'arme la plus puissante de cette
planète
tu dois la détruire
que veux-tu
je veux mon enfant  fr pour être en sécurité
rassemblez-vous autour des enfants
est-ce que quelqu'un connaît l'histoire des trois
petits cochons
le premier petit cochon a construit une maison
en paille
le deuxième petit papier a construit une
maison en bois
mais le troisième petit cochon il a construit une
maison en pierre
un  le jour où
un grand méchant loup est arrivé et a dit
petit cochon
et je vais faire exploser ta
maison  loup elle parlait
mère
c'est elle
toi